hi there um I want to thank everyone
that sent so many nice birthday
greetings to me it's a wonderful
wonderful feeling to be connected with
people all over the world in different
languages and I really appreciate it so
rather than individually replying to
everyone I I want to express my friends
here merci beaucoup muchas gracias xie
xie oh my god oh god I'm esta es pasivo
taxa Mickey Finn dunk when we got the
DOJ's I Jackie O jack will you multumesc
what am I forgotten here gratz here
obrigado I don't know I can go on thank
you very much I want to briefly talk
about what I found common between my
recent foray into cooking and language
learning now every day I spend three
hours or so chopping vegetables you know
researching what I'm going to cook on
the internet made a great I thought a
great lamb shank last night with lots of
vegetables you know which I basically
cooked or not email I guess like a pot
roast container that I put in the oven
and all that stuff but the thing but
about the cooking is that it's a 33 hour
by the time you prepare a job and cook
and stuff and then you clean up it's a
three out for me it's a three hour or
more operation and the food is eaten in
half an hour so you have to enjoy the
process which I do I enjoy the cooking I
really enjoyed and i'm now at the stage
where i can listen to my korean and cook
and I even enjoy shopping for the food
and language learning is like that
because you know we may not have
opportunities to speak all the time yeah
unless we're lucky enough to live where
the language is spoken however if we
enjoy the process for connecting just as
as with my cooking I'm getting closer to
these different vegetables and meats and
and and and obviously the shops where
they're sold and comparing the quality
and I find that it's it's stimulating
and the same with language running with
we can connect with the language with
the culture with the people if we find
that enjoyable the fact that we only
have and I you know limited
opportunities to use the language
needn't matter as long as we enjoy the
process so that will try it as always I
try to tie everything back to language
learning at any rate thank you very much
again for all the kind birthday
greetings bye for now